You guys want to do a, what is it? Uh,
yeah. Okay. Bakersfield,
um,
misconnections right here we go. My babies,
uh, one sec.
Okay, here we go. I mean,
when there's a type O in the
header is the best. Okay.
It says into Cici's first of all,
that's, so, eh,
but the Cici's is spelled with an apostrophe S into sissy, is
he writes in the body, where are they?
Latino looking for fun with them.
Do not contact me with unsolicited
services or offers
into Cici's. What is, by the way,
what even is that just like a guy is like, no,
a guy that's always like ill. If like sauce falls on their hands,
a guy that just like, if a car drives by really loud, they're just like,
is that, is that a sissy? This guy's looking to those kinds of guys.
Okay. Maybe shirt on tucked in the guy's just like, yeah. Yeah.
That guy, my feet hurt.
Yeah. I want to that guy.
That guy I'm into sissy is all right.
The next one. Oh my God, dude.
How do you up the header? Hey, what's going, ah,
Hey,
what's going the guy's so horny and Jack that he didn't even
finish typing the word on.
Oh my God, dude. The first sentence of this. Hey,
I mean the first sentence of this makes the header even better.
Hey, what's going so what's on ladies.
[inaudible] so what's on ladies.
By the way you missed going in that sentence. He's like, look,
you get one going,
you got to use it wisely and you get on you get one on and one going,
Hey, what's going. I guess I'll use it with so, so what's going,
I guess they'll assume the honors after that. And then what's on ladies.
I'll use the on there and then they'll figure out the going,
because they already heard it in the first one. Okay.
Male here seeing what's up on the Craigs. I was just thinking,
think about how I hate when guys do this. When they take the, when they,
when they shorten the noun and they put the in front of it, dude,
I was thinking about this yesterday. It's the most frat guy.
I hate it. When they say Justin Bieber,
they call him the Biebs or, or, or HIV.
They say the HIB, my mother, my mother.
That hurts my heart.
It's so not funny to me.
It's cause it's cute as.
It's you've heard somebody do that and now you all want to do it to my.
I'll make it work with my. It's so not,
it's so crazy to me when somebody says,
Hey, how's it going on? The cast for the pod. It's so cringy, dude.
Um,
any ladies from age 21 to 35 down to meet up for
NSA hookups. What's that nuts? NSA. NASA.
Oh yeah. No strings attached. That's right.
I have one get rid of comes through.
I've on keep yeah, dude straight and safe.
Hookups hit me up.
If you're interested with a subject other than the title of this post.
See ya. It's nice that he's says by at the end,
do not contact me with unsolicited services or offers.
Uh, wow.
This is a thug for real on the down-low.
Like he would never admit this to his, as you could tell,
just because the way it's the post is the,
the title is looking to get my ate.
It's eaten this guy's gangster though. Looking to get my ate,
looking at my, ate like he's afraid to tell the rest of the game. I was like,
yo dog, where we get D w w you haven't do that.
Will you find somebody to do that? Looking for someone to eat my for a while,
make me come a few times.
I am married top very DL send number and stats. In first email.
I like how this guy is right down to it.
Looking for someone to eat my for a while, make me come a few times.
I'm a married top,
very down low send number and stats. And first name stats.
I'm going to write back and write. My slugging percentage is five 20.
I've got 40 assessed.
Do not contact me with unsolicited services or offers.
Okay. Oh, Whoa,
dude. I love, Oh my God.
It's so awesome. How you can tell who the, who the foreigners are.
And it's not because of typos it's because they like this.
First of all, this is called Sonic drive in which I guess they met at,
they saw each other at a Sonic driving, which is a burger place
in white lane. You wished us a safe trip.
I'll miss your beautiful face foreign.
I wanted to swallow your in my dreams
foreign. I was the younger,
more fit old guy and rounding it out with the foreign.
Yes.
Do not contact me with unsolicited services or offers. I mean,
I want to swallow your coming. My dreams. You can do that without them,
just the guy's coming to my dreams.
Just, just
ruining my career straight up. That's the best doing the face like that,
do it like this. And then just doing this when the music gets in like that.
[inaudible] wow.
It's so funny how real it gets when you do do that.
Not that I've ever done it because I'm Christian,
but when you do do that, when you see porns and,
like no matter how gangster the girl is about like taking it and I've never
watched porn cause I'm Christian. But, um, when you,
when you, when the girl's like, yeah, yeah,
yeah. And then the, the, the, this, this,
this happens and they're just like,
like surreal immediately,
like me and then surreal immediately. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. And then it's like,
they're going to say, wait. Ah.
All right.
That's good with the misconnections and Bakersfield Bakersfield's gangster.